hasta ahorita hemos definido dos
determinantes el determinante para una
matriz de 2 por 2 y lo definimos tal
cual como tomar estas dos diagonales
tomar estas dos diagonales está ahí este
y multiplicamos a por d y le restamos b
por c ok y eso lo que nos queda es tal
cual a de menos bs entonces eso es el
determinante de una matriz de 2 por 2 y
en el vídeo pasado lo que hicimos fue
definir el determinante pero para
matrices de 3 por 3 y bueno la
definición fue tal cual tomar la primera
fila e ir agarrando cada una de las
entradas y multiplicar esas entradas por
el determinante de la sub matriz que nos
queda de eliminar la columna en la que
se encuentra la entrada y la fila en la
que se encuentra la entrada ok entonces
tomamos a 11 quitamos esta columna y
esta fila y le sacamos el determinante a
esta sub matriz que nos queda y bueno
para sacar el determinante de esta sub
matriz o sea éste
pues usábamos la definición que tenemos
para el determinante de matrices de 2
por 2 o sea de menos veces y después
cambia vamos de signo aquí tenemos un
signo más y entonces cambiábamos de
signo al signo menos y multiplicamos la
segunda entrada a 12 por el determinante
de la sub matriz que nos queda de
eliminar en esta columna y esta fila ok
entonces tenemos una matriz con estas
dos columnas y sacamos el determinante
de esa matriz ok este determinante
otra vez usando esta definición que
hicimos en otro vídeo de los
determinantes de matrices de 2 por 2 y
finalmente volvíamos a cambiar de signo
y entonces nos toca un signo más
y multiplicamos la última entrada que es
la entrada a 13 por el determinante de
la sub matriz que nos queda de eliminar
esta columna y esta fila que este
determinante y bueno en algún punto del
vídeo pasado yo dije que íbamos a
definir el determinante para cualquier
matriz de n por n y justo esto es lo que
vamos a hacer en este vídeo y pues vamos
a necesitar mucho espacio entonces
déjame recorro esto para encontrar más
espacio
aunque entonces déjame dibujar a mi
matriz a que va a tener n columnas y n
files pero en realidad debía haberlo
dicho al revés va a tener n filas y n
columna este denota las filas y este
denota las columnas entonces esta matriz
pues se va a ver vamos a usar la misma
anotación que usamos para las matrices
de 3 por 3 entonces vamos a poner aquí
puras as y vamos a usar un subíndice en
cada a el primer subíndice va a denotar
la fila en la que está y el segundo
subíndice va a denotar la columna en la
que está bueno en este caso es la 11
porque está en la primera fila y primera
columna ok pero este de aquí está en la
primera fila primera fila y en la
segunda columna ok aquí el siguiente
está en la primera fila tercera columna
y así pues tenemos muchas as por acá
hasta que llegamos
a la entrada a 1 m aunque hay porque
está en la primera fila y en la última
columna que es la enésima columna
y luego entonces tenemos que dibujar la
segunda fila y empieza con a 21 porque
está en la segunda fila primera columna
a 22 a 23
a 2 ene y si nos seguimos por aquí
llegamos hasta a n 1
y si nos vamos en diagonal pues por aquí
está el a n
bueno pero antes de definir el
determinante una matriz de nn gg + 0
otra definición
sí
ok vamos a definir la sub matriz
j esta matriz ay j va a ser la matriz
la matriz
que obtenemos
al ignorar
ignorar
tal vez debería yo decir eliminar pero
pues creo que vamos a dejarla aquí nada
más ignorar la
y así más fila y
ok la y la vamos a sacar de este primer
subíndice de esta ahí pero no sólo vamos
a ignorar la décima fila también vamos a
ignorar y la j
columna
te diría que veamos un ejemplo pero ya
tenemos varios a la mano así es que pues
vamos a verlos no si recuerdas en el
vídeo pasado hicimos esto varias veces
o sea aquí tenemos a 11 y eliminamos la
columna que tenía al 11 y la fila que
tenía la 11 ok entonces en realidad esta
matriz es tal cual la matriz a 11 no sea
eliminamos la primera fila en la primera
columna y de esta otra matriz pues lo
que hacíamos al eliminar la segunda
columna y la primera fila entonces esta
matriz de aquí de la cual le sacamos el
determinante es la matriz a 12 bueno de
hecho supongo que debería de ponerle así
porque estamos igualando este
determinante pero bueno y finalmente
esta otra matriz es tal cual la su
matriz a 13 bueno entonces regresemos a
donde estábamos
y pues ahora sí ya vamos a definir lo
que es el determinante una matriz de n
por m hay algo muy importante que se me
olvidó es decir que esta matriz la
matriz a y jota es una matriz de tamaño
n menos uno por ende menos uno aunque si
esta matriz es una matriz de siete por
siete o sea tiene siete filas y siete
columnas entonces está su matriz j va a
tener siete menos uno o sea seis seis
filas y seis columnas que iba a ser una
matriz de seis por seis y bueno estaba
pensando que el ejemplo que vimos tenía
puras letras entonces vamos a ver uno
con números que también vimos en el
vídeo pasado
aunque aquí teníamos la matriz ce y para
obtener esta matriz que está
multiplicando al 2 pues lo que hicimos
como está multiplicando al 2 fue tachar
la segunda columna y la primera fila
aunque ahí entonces y tachar la segunda
columna y la primera fila bueno debería
decirlo en el otro orden si tachamos la
primera fila y la segunda columna
entonces lo que esta matriz es es la
matriz a uno de que te echamos a la
primera fila y dos de que tachamos a la
segunda columna y lo que nos queda es
tal cual 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1
pero pero hay otro detalle muy
importante generalmente contamos
hablando de sus matrices no tiene por
qué siempre esta cosa hacer una aunque
hay como aquí esta matriz es una c
entonces generalmente a las sub matrices
lo que vamos a hacer es tomar el nombre
bueno la letra
original de la matriz de la cual está
saliendo esta sub matriz
esta letra ya lo ponemos los subíndices
correspondientes ok uno de que tachamos
la primera fila y dos de que tachamos la
segunda columna y bueno ya que tenemos
muy bien esta definición entonces ahora
sí vamos a definir el determinante para
matrices de n por n
y entonces para el caso de las matrices
de n por n
cuando sacamos la sub matriz por ejemplo
si queremos sacar la su matriz
11 entonces tomamos entonces quitamos la
primera fila y la primera columna y todo
lo que nos quede o sea todos estos
numeritos todos estos números conforman
la sub matriz a 11 y esa sí va a tener
una dimensión en el -1 por n menos uno
no sea porque estamos quitando la
primera fila y la primera columna
entonces aquí hay en sus filas y n menos
en columnas ok súper parecido a lo que
estábamos haciendo con las matrices de
tres por tres a ver déjame regreso toda
la normalidad
por ejemplo si queremos la sub matriz a
23 pues lo que hacemos es quitar esta
columna y esta fila
nos quedamos con la matriz que tiene a
estas entradas
y hagan de cuenta que le ponemos aquí un
pegamento
y ya tenemos a nuestra nueva sub matriz
a 23 que entonces ahora sí a ver si ya
vamos a definir el determinante de una
matriz de adn por n te va a aparecer
como una definición súper circular o sea
tal vez superficialmente va a parecer
que estamos despidiendo al determinante
en términos del mismo determinante pero
hay un detalle que hace que esto tenga
todo el sentido del mundo nada más que
déjame borró todo esto para dejar las
cosas súper claras
entonces vamos a definir el determinante
de una matriz de n n en este caso es la
matriz a como vamos a tomar la primera
entrada vamos a tomar la primera entrada
a 11 con un signo más y la vamos a
multiplicar por el determinante de la
sub matriz que nos queda de eliminar a
la fila y a la columna que contienen a
esta entrada a 11 ok pero eso por
definición es la matriz a 1-1 ok
estamos eliminando la primera fila y la
primera columna por la cual estamos
sacando el determinante de la matriz a
1-1
aunque bueno sabes que déjame mejor lo
escribo de otra forma
y déjame lo escribo como el determinante
de la matriz a 1
y ahora nos vamos a cambiar a la
siguiente entrada de la primera fila
pero nos vamos a cambiar de signo todo
el tiempo vamos a estar cambiando de
signo aquí empezamos con un mes entonces
ahorita nos toca un menos y entonces
vamos a tomar la segunda entrada a 12 y
la vamos a multiplicar por el
determinante de lo que nos queda de
quitar esta columna y esta fila que son
las columnas y las filas que contienen a
la entrada a 12 y de lo que nos queda
ósea de esta y la pegada a el resto de
esta matriz que es una sub matriz porque
es exactamente la sub matriz a 12 la sub
matriz a 12
pues vamos a multiplicar por el
determinante de esta sub matriz su
determinante y entonces como aquí
estábamos restando ahora lo que nos va a
tocar es sumar que porque vamos
cambiando de signo y tenemos a la
entrada a 13 a 13 que vamos a
multiplicar por el determinante de la
sub matriz a 13
ok porque eliminamos la primera fila y
la tercera columna que son las pilas y
las columnas que contienen a la entrada
a 13 y después pues vamos con la
siguiente entrada pero nos toque aún
menos y después de esa entrada pues nos
va a tocar un mes y así nos vamos a
seguir más menos más menos con las
entradas correspondientes y los
determinantes de las sub matrices
correspondientes hasta que pues llegamos
a la última entrada y entonces cuando
llegamos a la última entrada dependiendo
de cómo sea n pues nos puede tocar
o nos puede tocar un menos todos los
subíndices de las columnas pares les
está tocando al menos y a todos los
subíndices de las columnas impares les
está tocando el más ok el chiste es que
eventualmente vamos a sumar el último
término a uno n y lo vamos a multiplicar
por el determinante de la sub matriz
ah1n y habremos terminado ya tendremos
el determinante de la matriz a y justo
en este segundo tú tienes que decir oye
sal cómo puede estar esta definición
bien o sea estas definiendo al
determinante de una matriz en términos
de otros determinantes y esos
determinantes como demonios los vamos a
sacar pero bueno resulta que hay un
truco por aquí y el truco es que estos
determinantes también son determinantes
pero aquí estamos sacando el
determinante de matrices más pequeñas o
sea esta es una matriz de n por m pero
estas matrices son de dimensión n 1 n 1
y entonces como puedes preguntar bueno
de todas formas no sabemos cómo sacar el
determinante de matrices de n menos uno
por n menos 1 y el chiste aquí es volver
a aplicar la fórmula ok y escribir este
determinante en términos de matrices de
n 2 por ende menos 2 y así te vas n
menos dos pasos hasta llegar a
determinantes de 2 x 2
ok simplemente tienes que sustituir toda
esta fórmula en cada uno de estos
determinantes hasta que las dimensiones
de las sub matrices de las cuales
estamos sacando determinante sean
matrices de 2 por 2 porque esos
determinantes si los tenemos definidos
aunque esta es una definición recursiva
así le llamamos a las definiciones que
tienen esta forma entonces para sacar el
determinante de la matriz tienes que
encontrar el determinante de las sub
matrices a 11 a 12 y así hasta a 1 n
pero para encontrar determinante de cada
una de esas sus matrices pues tenemos
que volver a aplicar la fórmula
hasta
hasta llegar a matrices tan chicas que
sean del tamaño 2 por 2 en cuyo caso ya
tenemos su determinante definido está
aquí es de bs ok ab - bc y entonces ahí
sí ya tenemos construida toda la
pirámide aunque podrías construirlo todo
con el determinante de 3 por 3 no tienes
que llegar hasta el de 2 por 2 pero pues
realmente es mucho más sencillo hacerlo
con el de 2 x 2 además de que está este
determinante de 3 por 3 no es más que un
caso particular del caso general aunque
hay donde nuestra matriz adn por n pues
es una matriz de 3 por 3 y si te picas
ésta tal cual como la fórmula aquí
tenemos la primera entrada la primera
entrada multiplicada por su sub matriz
a 11 y después cambiamos de signo y la
segunda entrada por el determinante de
la menor a 12 y finalmente volvemos a
cambiar de signo y nos queda más la
tercera entrada por el determinante de
la sub matriz a 13 ok este determinante
de las matrices de 3 por 3 es
simplemente un caso particular del caso
general en la fórmula que acabamos de
escribir allá abajo
este tipo de definición como les estaba
diciendo hace rato es una definición
recursiva
d
y yo
y en este tipo de definiciones uno
define lo que quiere definir en términos
de esto mismo pero con una versión un
poco más simple que hay para encontrar
estas definiciones volvemos a tomar toda
esta fórmula pero la aplicamos a esta
matriz y el chiste aquí es que estas
matrices tienen una dimensión un poco
más chica entonces con cada iteración si
aquí en lugar de tener este determinante
de a 11 metemos toda la fórmula pero con
a 11 aquí y pues las sub matrices
correspondientes y repetimos eso una y
otra y otra y otra y otra vez como vamos
a obtener matrices cada vez más pequeñas
eventualmente vamos a llegar a una
matriz de 2 por 2 y así es como
funcionan las definiciones recursivas o
sea tenemos lo que queremos definir en
términos de lo mismo que queremos
definir pero en términos más sencillos
que al fin y al cabo al aplicarlo muchas
veces eventualmente vamos a llegar a un
paso base que en este caso es el
determinante de una matriz de dos por
dos
es el caso base si no puede estar
definido en términos de otros
determinantes ese paso si tienen que
estar bien definidos y ese es el caso de
nuestro determinante de 2 por 2 pero
bueno no estamos satisfechos con tantas
letras para que quede todo claro hoy
vamos a sacar el determinante de una
matriz de 4x4 entonces necesitamos más
espacio
1 2 3 4
0 1 2 3 y 2 3 0
que hay entonces queremos sacar el
determinante de esta matriz y para no
volver a escribirla simplemente le voy a
borrar estas patitas a los paréntesis
para que esto denota que es un
determinante entonces vamos a empezar
siempre son la primera fila está
disponible aquí un igual y tomamos la
primera entrada que son 1 x y lo vamos a
multiplicar por la sub matriz que nos
queda de eliminar esta fila y esta
columna ok si esto es la matriz a este
determinante de aquí vamos a ponerlo así
este determinante de aquí
sería el determinante de la matriz a 1-1
pero pues aquí lo vamos a escribir tal
cual
entonces nos queda 0 20 123 300
y después como aquí estamos sumando
ahora nos toca restar aunque no estamos
restando la segunda entrada de la
primera fila dos por el determinante
de la matriz que nos queda de eliminar
la fila en la que está y la columna en
la que está ok entonces dentro de este
determinante tenemos que poner 1 2 0
120 me estoy saltando este 0 porque está
en la misma columna que el 2 aunque
entonces en la segunda fila 0 2 3
0 2 3 y finalmente 2 0
y ahora tenemos un menos y vamos a
cambiar de signo entonces nos toca aún
más
la tercera entrada por el determinante
de 100 100 aquí y ahora tenemos que
ignorar al 2 porque se encuentra en la
misma columna que el 3 y no queremos
tomarlo en cuenta porque estamos
siguiendo esta definición de
determinante y aquí nos dicen que
estamos sacándole el determinante a la
sub matriz a 13 y la sub matriz a 13 no
toma en cuenta esta columna entonces la
siguiente fila tiene 0 1 3
0 1 3 y finalmente 2 3 0
y para terminar pues tenemos más menos
más o sea que toque a menos la última
entrada en la primera columna por el
determinante de la sub matriz que
contiene a todas las columnas menos a la
última columna y no tiene contiene la
primera fila sea ésta su matriz y nos
queda el determinante de 1 0 2
122 30
que queremos sacar el determinante de
una matriz de 4x4 y usando la fórmula en
la definición de determinante reducimos
esto a encontrar cuatro determinantes de
tres por tres okey porque es una
definición recursiva y bueno ya que
todos estos determinantes son de tres
por tres pues arriba tenemos la fórmula
para encontrar estos determinantes de
tres por tres o podemos volver a usar la
fórmula recursiva de nuestra definición
de determinante bn por n nada más que
ahorita la n va a ser 3 en lugar de 4 y
así termina de encontrar este
determinante aquí entonces todo esto va
a ser exactamente igual a 1 x y este
determinante este determinante vamos a
empezar lo tenemos aquí 0
pero por el determinante
pues tachamos la primera fila y la
primera columna que hacemos que
contienen a este cero y nos queda nada
más
esta sub matriz que ahora ya son a su
matriz de 2 x 2 lo cual es muy
conveniente la sub matriz
2 300 ok entonces aquí empezamos sumando
y ahora nos toca restar la segunda
entrada o sea 2 por el determinante de
quitamos la columna que lo contiene y la
fila que lo contiene entonces nada más
nos queda 13
13 30 y como acabamos de restar ahora
nos toca sumar la última entrada que es
0 por el determinante de esta su matriz
ok
12 30
entonces ya terminamos con este
determinante así es que vamos ahora con
este para empezar tenemos un -2 por
afuera que no tiene nada que ver con el
determinante que está multiplicando
empezamos con este 1 nos queda este
determinante 1 x
2300 menos porque antes estábamos un -2
por lo que nos queda de quitar esta
columna y esta fila 2 por el
determinante de 0 3 2 0
03 20 finalmente más 0 por el
determinante de a que tenemos aquí el 0
y creemos este determinante ok
220 y ahora vamos con este otro
determinante de 3 por 3 aquí estábamos
gastando entonces más 3 por tomamos la
primera entrada y eliminamos la columna
que lo contiene y la fila que lo
contiene y nos queda 13 30 entonces uno
por
13 30
entonces nos toca restar la segunda
entrada
0 por el determinante de lo que nos
queda de quitar esta columna y bueno
también en esta fila entonces es
03 20 y como estábamos restando nos toca
asume la última entrada que es un cero
por el determinante de la sub matriz a
13 y la sub matriz a 13 lo que hace
estar esta columna y esta fila o sea 0 1
2 3
muy bien y finalmente ya fue un montón
de cálculos pero finalmente ya estamos a
tres cuartas partes del camino ya nada
más tenemos que calcular este último
determinante de tres por tres pero este
va a estar sencillo digo igual que los
anteriores entonces menos cuatro por
usando la fórmula claro
uno por el determinante
este determinante de aquí
entonces estábamos sumando nos toca
restar restar este 0-0 por el
determinante de quitamos esta fila y
esta columna y nos queda 0 2 2 0
pero todos 20
y como estábamos restando ahora nos toca
sumar
la última entrada 2 por el determinante
el determinante de la sub matriz a 13
sea quitamos la tercera columna y la
primera fila y nos queda 0 1 2 3 0 1 2 3
0 1 2 3 y listo listo ya nada más
tenemos que hacer las cuentas a ver para
hacer las cuentas vamos a usar un color
muy llamativo y lo primero que vamos a
hacer para no estar sacando
determinantes que no necesitamos atacar
pues vamos a eliminar de una vez todos
los que se van a multiplicar por 0 o sea
porque 0 por cualquier número es 0
aunque entonces aquí tenemos un 0 y al
multiplicarlo por nuestro determinante
todo esto es un gran 0 menos chiquito
como quieras este de aquí también es un
0 porque se está multiplicando por un
cero
esto es un 0
y aquí tenemos otro cero
y otro cero aquí también se está
multiplicando por un 0 y finalmente
nuestro último cero y ahora sí ya
tenemos menos determinantes de 2 por 2
que necesitamos es que hemos llegado a
la base de nuestra definición recursiva
entonces pues vamos a sacar este
determinante es 1 x 0
este es a de menos bc que es 3 x 3 ok
entonces uno por cero es cero menos tres
por tres que es 9 aunque entonces nos
queda nada más menos 9 que luego es
súper hiper importante que no se nos
olvide multiplicarlo por este menos 2 y
luego por este 1 a mí ya se me estaba
olvidando este 1
el chiste aquí y ahora es que no nos
equivoquemos a la hora de hacer las
cuentas porque ahí es donde todo el
mundo se equivoca yo me equivoco
muchísimo en esto pero en este vídeo no
me voy a equivocar bueno eso creo verdad
porque entonces sigamos con este
aquí tenemos dos por cero que es cero
menos tres por cero que es cero entonces
aunque lo multiplicamos primero por uno
y después por menos dos nos va a seguir
quedando cero si es que éste es otro
cero y ahora vamos con este esto es un
cero por cero
0 - 2 por 3 2 por 3 y 6 o sea que
tenemos un -6 que vamos a tener que
multiplicar por menos dos primero y
después por el otro menos dos por acá
este determinante es uno por cero
0 - 3 por 3 9 que nos queda menos 9 por
1 por 3 y aquí tenemos 1 por 0 0 menos
dos por tres
esto es 6 menos 6 por 1 por menos 4 y
finalmente ahora si finalmente 0 por 30
menos uno por 2-2 nuestro menos 2 por 2
por menos 4
tenemos uno por aquí tenemos menos dos
por menos nueve
los dos por menos nueve más puros ceros
y después tenemos menos dos por menos
dos por menos 6
- 2 x menos 6
después tenemos 3 x 1 x menos 9
3 x 1 x menos 9
y finalmente tenemos menos 4 x
1 - 6 1
no por menos
más menos 4 por 2 por menos 2 gay menos
4 por 2 por menos 2
muy bien y todo esto ahora ya nada más
tenemos que hacer las cuentas y hacerlas
muy bien para no equivocarnos entonces
esto es igual a 1 x menos 2 x menos 9
este menos se cancela con este menos y
nos queda nada más dos por 9 que es 18
por 1 sigue siendo 18 y aquí menos 2 por
menos 6 este menos se cancela con este y
nos queda 2 por 6 12 por menos 2 eso es
menos 24
y de aquí uno por menos nueve y luego
todo eso por tres o sea menos 27 menos
27 y finalmente aquí tenemos 1 por menos
6 que es menos 6 + 2 por menos 2 que es
menos 4 o sea menos 6 menos 4 que es
menos 10 por menos 4 eso nos queda más
entonces restando vamos a empezar a
contestar este con este 18 menos 24 es
menos 6
y luego restemos este de aquí 40 menos
27 es 13
y finalmente 13 - 6 entonces todo esto
nos queda igual a 7
listo por fin ya terminamos ya
calculamos el determinante de esa matriz
de 4x4
el determinante de esta matriz después
de tantos cálculos si no cometimos
ningún error de cuentas pero espero que
no entonces este determinante es
exactamente igual a 7 y bueno esto lo
que nos dice es que esta matriz si es
invertible porque su determinante es
distinto de 0 recuerda que una de las
características super padres de los
determinantes es que si el determinante
de una matriz si el determinante de a es
distinto de 0 bueno esto pasa si y sólo
si a es invertible
y ver ti
esta es la gran propiedad de los
determinantes tienen algunas otras cosas
muy lindas pero esta es la más
importante un determinante es distinto
de cero si y sólo si la matriz es
invertible ok entonces ya sabemos sacar
determinantes de matrices de n por n nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo